extremely emotional alec baldwin
speaking out tonight telling his side of
the story what happened on the set of
the movie shooting rust and the fatal
shooting of cinematographer helena
hutchins take a look
she was someone who was loved by
everyone who worked with and liked by
everyone who worked with and admired
[Music]
i'm sorry
later in the interview baldwin went into
great detail telling georgie
stephanopoulos his version of the
secrets of events take a look
so you have this cold 45 you just pulled
the hammer as far back as i could
without cocking the actuator and you're
holding on to the hammer i'm holding
that i'm just showing i go how about
that does that work you see that do you
see that you said she goes yeah that's
good i let go of the hammer bang the gun
goes
everyone is horrified
they're shocked
uh it's loud
they don't have their earplugs in no one
was the gun was supposed to be empty i
was told i was handed an empty gun or if
there were cosmetic grounds nothing with
a charge at all a flash round nothing
she goes down
i thought to myself
did she faint
the notion that there was a live round
in that gun
did not dawn on me till probably 45
minutes to an hour later
here with reaction fox news contributor
leo 2.0 terrell the co-host of the clay
travis buck sexton show out kick founder
clay travis let's look at it from a
legal standpoint leo and that is guns
don't fire themselves uh he's admitting
he cocked the hammer now if you start
cocking the hammer and you don't click
it in
and
you can discharge that firearm does he
have the responsibility himself to check
to see if that weapon is loaded with
live ammunition
yes and i want to be very clear as a
lawyer let me tell you this interview
was a preempted strike they know there's
going to be charges coming down they
don't know who's going to be charged
no one should believe that he gave that
interview without being consulted by his
lawyers
no one should believe that that wasn't
rehearsed i want to see the raw footage
if
this interview was being done strictly
to basically influence the jury pool and
to get his version out there now he's
committed to this version so you can
expect this over and over again this is
a strategy by his lawyers let's not be
fooled by this it was a very sad
situation but the call of your question
he has a responsibility and his
attorneys know that sean and they see
something coming down with the
investigation the first of next year
now clay if you agree with leo and that
this was a legal strategy
and every i was dotted and t was crossed
in terms of what alec baldwin said
tonight
i guess you'd have to add to that he's
also an actor
i've done one film sam sorbo
numerous takes i played myself and on
cue without fail every single solitary
take it was a scene in which she cried
and it was believable and and honestly i
i couldn't i could not do that i i
wouldn't have i can't cry in real life
anyway but
you get the point in other words so
leo's right
and you
now do we have to ask the question
was this rehearsed did he act is it real
i mean it comes off as somewhat sincere
to me
well yeah these are all really good
questions sean i think leo's right too
and this is you know me kind of
analyzing this from a legal perspective
as well uh having done some criminal law
in my career i had the same reaction as
leo they're not going to tell this story
unless they are committed that is going
to remain 100 percent consistent
throughout now and to me there's a
couple of questions that really come
into play here one the d.a is going to
have to decide whether or not to bring
charges and who to bring charges against
because there was negligence there's no
way that when you look at the facts in
this situation somehow that gun was
loaded whether or not alec baldwin
pulled the trigger or not i would think
there would be cameras something to
reflect what might have actually
happened there it seems unlikely the gun
discharged without some sort of ability
or action that he undertook that doesn't
mean that he's criminally culpable i'm
sure he's going to be sued in every
civil court imaginable with as many
different accounts as you can imagine
but what is going to happen here there's
negligence was it civil negligence or
was it criminal negligence because
that's the difference between let's say
a manslaughter charge and alec baldwin
and other people involved in this case
being hit probably with a verdict in the
tens of millions of dollars and you're
right sean and i'm sure leo thinks about
this too you're talking about one of
whatever you think about alec baldwin
he's one of the great actors of his
generation so if he can cry on command
when things actually aren't real i'm
sure that he can also master this for a
jury for a judge for a prosecutor for
everybody out there that he would be
talking to and be imminently believable
whether or not it's true
leo he said george clooney said you have
protocols you check the gun every time
stephanopoulos asked if he felt guilty
said no someone is responsible for what
happened but i know it's not me if i
thought i was responsible i probably
would have killed myself
um
is george clooney right
well i'll tell you right now clooney is
right to the fact that baldwin had a
responsibility
but what you just read and what you just
stated baldwin has no problem throwing
everybody else under the bus he knows
he's going to be questioned under oath
either as clay says civilly criminally
or at a deposition and what you just
heard is a is his text i want to see the
raw footage i want to see the interview
between the tiers before and after the
tier i want to see if there's laughter
so district attorney sheriff department
get the raw footage of that interview
because that's edited down hey listen
a horrible situation but he did not do
this interview without being coached by
lawyers i stayed 30 years on it lawyers
were involved
clay i didn't know you're a lawyer and
then here you are now you're selling
let's go brandon t-shirts what happened
i mean i've fallen off the wagon in a
big way sean uh my law school classmates
call me on it every day here's the other
thing by the way i gotta run trump can
you imagine what baldwin would have done
if trump had been accused of this it's
crazy hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else